[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional de france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco como no
podía ser de otra forma
en eeuu con la resaca de unas elecciones
que atención puede alargarse hasta el
próximo mes de enero hasta que el
próximo inquilino de la casa blanca tome
el poder para ello me acompañan en este
estudio de román un periodista de france
24 que acaba de llegar ahora mismo de
eeuu el recorrido digamos todos los
territorios que donald trump conquistó
en 2016 bienvenidos román hola carlos
buen día de amigo merchán o también
compañero de france 24 bienvenido david
hola buenos días desde washington el
corresponsal de revisar bien y la sabía
buenos días que tal buenos días y
también en unos instantes estará también
con nosotros aquí un historiador de
prestigio muy conocedor de la historia
de eeuu como es james coin de la
universidad de parís
3 eeuu largas resaca electoral hoy en
primera plana
bueno pues un escrutinio agónico un
presidente que afirma fraude sin mostrar
pruebas el temor a que se produzcan
actos violentos en las calles y como si
todo esto fuese poco un prólogo que
parece va judicial izarse durante las
próximas semanas si algo nos deja las
elecciones de eeuu es un país más
dividido que nunca y no no hubo ola full
demócrata que arrasará contra amp sino
que más bien el aún presidente resistió
mucho mejor de lo que muchos analistas
pensaron las elecciones en eeuu nos
dejan sus maniobras por atrincherarse al
poder con su estilo habitual y
cuestionando los propios fundamentos de
la democracia estadounidense sin aportar
ninguna prueba eso sí por menciones de
tipo personal
denunciando fraudes sin pruebas
la misma noche es de electoral y del
otro lado el candidato yo iba llamando a
la prudencia ya que se contarán todos
los votos
durante un escrutinio que se ha ido
alargando esta dinámica aún puede
continuar el presidente asegura que
litigar ha hasta el final pero hasta
dónde piensa llegar esa quizá sea la
duda vamos a repasar antes algunas
portadas antes de preguntar a mis
invitados washington post' una nación
dividida dice el rotativo que el
resultado de una carrera tan estrecha
entre candidatos provocó una división
aún superior financial times' duelo al
filo del cuchillo entre ambos candidatos
aquí en francia el diario le monde
titula by the tramp eeuu se rompe
primera pregunta casi básica eeuu sale
de estas elecciones como un país más
dividido a un romano
pensó que eeuu ya es dividido toda la
gente que tiene hablando estos últimos
días me han dirigido
muchas familias amigos se dividen con
trump
lo amas o lo odias no hay en claro vemos
a un presidente david ensuciando los
fundamentos del sistema democrático y
por otro lado un candidato con un tono
mucho más presidencialista no sí es
increíble lo que está parado
si la actuación de trump estaba muy
preocupante que en general en eeuu
aunque hay tensiones y enfrentamientos
entre políticos muy fuertes al final
como es tradición decir bueno he perdido
la elección y
y bueno es buena
y dijo y dijo lo mejor para mi sucesor o
para el que la influencia democrática
que ahora mismo está totalmente borrada
esa tradición que existe existen en eeuu
y bueno de tales parece muy poco
probable y eso es un poco preocupante
xavi ávila washington hasta dónde puede
llegar tranquilizarse a la pregunta
acorralado en las semanas que le quedan
de estar para petra do en la casa blanca
hasta que haya el cambio de poder el
próximo mes de enero bueno él quiere
elevar esto al supremo a las más altas
instancias judiciales consciente de
todos modos de que éstas estos entuertos
de recuentos y en cuanto se llevan a la
justicia normalmente se definen en
juzgados de menor instancia a nivel
estatal por lo tanto esto es un echar
una patada a la pelota hacia adelante
seguir dominando el relato y situar su
marca conservadora delante del partido
republicano para que no se pierda caso
que él pierda la elección y quién sabe
si volver
en el 2024 vamos a añadir un punto de
vista más de alguien que conoce a la
perfección eeuu y cuyo análisis es un
honor sumar en primera plana james con
el historiador especialista de eeuu sin
el wayne estas elecciones más allá del
resultado final dejan dos conclusiones
que sí parecen definitivas las encuestas
fallaron de nuevo trump no era ningún
accidente temporal y el país sufre una
fractura profunda los observa si usted
buenos días
buenos días necesito saber lo que dicen
los sondeos pero nunca tomo muy en serio
los sondeos porque sé que hay siempre
cosas más complicadas que están pasando
hay toda una categoría de gente que
prefiere no contestar porque saben que
si usted dice trump de la impresión y
mejor no contestar también hay toda una
categoría de gente que no contesta por
teléfono celular sino más fácil llegar a
estas personas por no sé por instagram
por los jóvenes que este tipo de
problema explicó y metodológico para los
sondeos
quiero decir sobre todo es que la
metodología de los sondeos
aunque sea muy muy buena nunca llega a
tener toda la riqueza de lo que sería
como un estudio sociológico de la
población y así llegamos a la segunda
partida de pregunta la fractura de la
sociedad es tan yo creo que sí esta
fractura está ahí ya estaba en el 2016 y
ahora con cuatro años de poder de trump
mucho más porque hay gente que se afirma
como trompista ahora más que nunca
también hay un problema de resentimiento
un problema de frustración que tiene que
ver con la situación socioeconómica de
mucha gente que no conoce la movilidad
social que antes tenía y eso se traduce
para ellos en una forma de nacionalismo
con muros a solís va con una identidad
muy muy clara nosotros aquí ustedes ella
bueno la pregunta que tenemos ahora es
claro todas estas maniobras de donald
trump a evitar su derrota si pueden
marcar el futuro de eeuu con sus
seguidores más radicalizados mi
compañero román ha recorrido digamos el
mapa de esos estados
del lado de tram en 2016 estamos
hablando de sobre todo de un voto de
adhesión a diferencia del de joe biden
que podría ser un voto para que no salga
atrás pero el de transit que es un voto
de adhesión a un programa que te puede
gustar más o menos pero que sí que claro
que si la gente que vota vota al fútbol
gama a sus ideas y su estilo ham ha
construido un personaje un personaje de
televisión
su característica principal sería ganar
ganar ganar
la derrota muy mal selene luther es algo
que no pasa por su cabeza no sí y tengo
un ejemplo muy concreto fui a wyoming
donde todavía se vive de la industria
del carbón y ahí luz el hecho que de
defender el carbón lo ha llevado el
estado de manera muy fácil no puede
imaginar votar un demócrata porque y la
ley quinto en el dicho que se ha
cambiado el jabón joven dice que quiere
una transición hacia energías más copias
entonces son es el único que los
dirección de defiende a los que se
consideran como olvidados de la médica
david la ola azul demócrata no se
produjo y lo que sí que se confirma con
esa cantidad de votos porque al fin y al
cabo
todos los que han votado trump tromba ha
resistido mejor de lo previsto trump
esto se confirma que no era ningún
accidente tram como muchos quisieron ver
la transformación del partido
republicano es increíble porque ahora no
sólo traban pero cuando se escucha el
discurso de muchos republicanos se
parece mucho más a la derecha que unos
años atrás hasta hasta discursos de
extrema derecha que tienen candidatos a
diferentes puestos en el congreso
los seguidores de trump el partido
republicano ha cambiado totalmente se
instaló
todo lo que era el discurso de tron de
2016 que era nuevo que era
para muchos una algo raro ahora es
totalmente normal dentro del partido
republicano esa bebida más allá de la
elección presidencial hay otras batallas
que se están dando ahora mismo y que
parecen básicas por ejemplo por el
control del senado se estrecharía mucho
el margen de maniobra para joe vaivén
como presidente si los republicanos
controlan el senado
mucho del todo de la sastrería carlos sí
sí porque fíjate que es una cámara
legislativa en este sistema sin la cual
no se puede adelantar legislación y el
ejemplo más concreto lo tenemos muy
reciente el obamacare es un caso claro
de lo que pasó incluso igual es decir lo
van a querer sólo pudo echarse adelante
porque en el primer mandato
obama tenía las dos cámaras legislativas
a su favor el partido demócrata las
controlaba pero sólo los dos primeros
años de una administración en la casa
blanca con su partido en las dos cámaras
permiten avanzar legislación este no va
a ser el caso porque el senado va a
seguir en manos republicanas todo indica
y por lo tanto una hipotética
administración de bailén
lo va a tener muy complicado para poder
echar adelante lo que tiene en mente
román david qué pensáis la gestión de la
pandemia ha sido un factor tan
definitivo es decir si el coronavirus no
hubiese existido pongámonos hace un año
como tal como iba la economía hoy
estaríamos hablando de un claro segundo
mandato de donald trump no haciendo un
poco hipótesis
ganados y sin la pandemia porque hace un
año la economía
era estupenda pero también llegaron las
encuestas que la pandemia no fue un
factor decisivo por el voto de publicado
que solo para los demócratas la gestión
de donald trump
le impacta los del público que hizo lo
máximo y que para ellos
la manera de
y gestionar la pandemia es algo que
tiene a hacer a sí mismo es decía qué
estoy mal entonces tengo que irme pero
no necesito el gobierno para hacerlo
davis hubiera ganado donald tramos en el
coronavirus eso nunca pero cambio la
elección cambio la campaña totalmente y
baile y bueno desde desde francia desde
europa
creo que muchos tenemos
queremos estamos no queremos a donald
trump está muy extraño para la cultura
política aquí
pero eso también se puede discutir una
breve pausa para la vuelta de hábitat
quiero preguntar sobre las repercusiones
de todos estos movimientos de donald
trump en américa latina vemos que no
están en primera plana
[Música]
cerca del 30 de las camas de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos están
ocupadas por pacientes con kobe 19 lo
que en términos absolutos se traduce en
unos 2.800 ingresados en la actualidad
por esta razón y si nos fijamos en las
cifras de hace un mes vemos como ha
habido un aumento de más de 10 puntos
pero estamos hablando de la situación en
general de la media de españa pero es
especialmente preocupante en 9
comunidades autónomas donde esta cifra
de ocupación supera el 35% es el caso de
la rioja de aragón de cataluña o de
madrid entre otras y lo que preocupa
sobre todo al personal sanitario es que
a pesar de que se conozca mejor la
enfermedad y por lo tanto se pueda
procurar también un mejor tratamiento
que mejore las expectativas de las
personas que ingresan en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos si continúan a los
contagios en aumento se puede llegar de
nuevo a un colapso hospitalario que
genere una fuerte competencia entre
pacientes tanto kobe cómo no kobe por
obtener una cama en estas unidades
[Música]
francia volvió a confinarse y sin
embargo los casos de coronavirus siguen
aumentando de manera exponencial de
hecho durante la primera semana de
noviembre que fue también la primera
semana de confinamiento se llegaron
hasta los 4000 casos de ingreso en
reanimación de pacientes con comida de
19 a sabiendas de que en francia hay
unas 6.000 camas en estos servicios a
diferencia de la primavera francia no
podrá esta vez enviar pacientes a los
países vecinos ya que en toda europa se
está luchando contra esta epidemia por
ahora ha habido transferencia de
pacientes entre diferentes regiones y
también de hospitales públicos hacia
clínicas privadas
olivia de ron el ministro de salud
indicaba que el espera haya un pico del
número de ingresos en reanimación cerca
de 6000 hacia mediados de noviembre que
a partir de ese momento estas cifras
deberían comenzar a disminuir pero
teniendo en cuenta un promedio bastante
importante y es que 1 de cada 4
pacientes que ingresan en reanimación no
suele salir con vida
[Música]
bélgica con la incidencia de casos más
elevada de europa de coronavirus está
desbordada a diferencia de la primera
ola los hospitales han estado en las
últimas semanas al borde de quedarse sin
camas y de unidades de cuidados
intensivos por ello el gobierno ha
lanzado un plan para que haya 800 camas
adicionales en los hospitales para hacer
frente a la avalancha de casos a partir
de ahora los hospitales tendrán que
dedicar un 60% de camas a los pacientes
más graves de coronavirus en las últimas
semanas el país ha puesto medidas mucho
más restrictivas como el 'toque de
queda' también el cierre de la
hostelería también de las tiendas para
que se reduzcan los casos de hecho se
han ralentizado pero aún así los casos
siguen siendo muy elevados así lo alerta
el personal sanitario que asegura que a
pesar de todo no hay que bajar la
guardia porque en la transmisión
comunitaria del virus sigue siendo muy
elevada en todo el país
[Música]
miles de personas cada año se ven
obligadas al éxodo a huir de sus países
en busca de una vida mejor
llevamos una mirada humana a la
migración masiva en américa latina y en
el resto del mundo
acompáñenme inmigrantes por france 24 y
france 24 punto com
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana hoy analizando
toda la resaca que dejan las elecciones
de eeuu con dos compañeros míos de
france24 román ue y david comer sano con
el historiador james cohen y con el
corresponsal de recién washington
xavier en vila xavi silva den se
confirma como presidente el próximo mes
de enero más allá de las maniobras que
pueda ejercer tram durante todo este
tiempo que es lo que puede que es lo
sustancial del cambio por ejemplo en
materia climática parece más o menos
claro que sí que habrá un cambio pero no
tanto en las relaciones con china donde
podría seguir un poco la misma senda que
trancó al cual el principal cambio de
que llegara en el poder
bueno yo quizá lo podemos discernir
entre cuestión interna así que está
claro porque si esto no descubrimos nada
que con byd en los impuestos van a
volver a más gente a las rentas
superiores a 400.000 dólares que para
muchos de nuestros espectadores puede
parecer una barbaridad de dinero por lo
que aquí es una renta familiar
relativamente común especialmente las
dos costas no en el centro del país esto
en cuanto a cuestión interna quizás sea
lo más relevante de la diferencia entre
uno
en cuestión internacional tienes mucha
razón que inicialmente la relación con
china que está basada en la desconfianza
mutua no va a cambiar en esencia luego
la cuestión de los aranceles y de las
relaciones comerciales seguramente
seguiría puliendo progresivamente en una
administración baiden y sería vamos si
me permite ser la expresión más amable
la relación entre uno y el otro por lo
menos habría un diálogo que no tan
agresivo que es lo de marca de la casa
de trump de empezar en una posición de
máximos y progresivamente irse un paso
atrás para encontrar consensos
os quiero preguntar david román damos
por sentado que la presidencia de baile
no es una transición de un solo mandato
producido como efecto para parar a trump
en el que además esté limitado su agenda
o le otorga una autonomía propia una
personalidad propia como para dejar
impronta y que se pueda llegar a hablar
de una era vaivén donde os situamos en
la transición o en la impronta propia
cádiz es complicado hacer supuestos pero
bueno
bueno cualquier cosa si yo vaivén llega
a ser el próximo presidente de eeuu él
va a tener un problema que la mayoría en
el senado parece que va a quedarse con
los republicanos y los cambios en la
corte suprema que hizo trump va a hacer
que su gestión va a ser bajo el control
de los republicanos eso eso es lo que
podemos decir ahora el resto es sólo
especulación me parece como el pienso
también que vamos a ver una transición
cuando bailan por qué
pero no es una revolución sino de
consenso todo su carrera lo demuestra
siempre ha sido intentando
rechazar un consenso con los
republicanos y quizás es lo que necesita
luz esa luz y luz ahora porque son más
divididos que nunca lo que parece claro
es que mientras el voto hacía trampa la
elección de otra han tenido acierte tras
una cierta ilusión una cierta adhesión
la de bailén no lo tiene es un voto
contra trump
bueno pareció también que en el 2016
no ganó fue un rechazo a hillary clinton
esta vez bueno me parece no no me parece
muy claro lo que la hay mucha gente que
tiene miedo de trump en eeuu
y bueno quizás baile no es el candidato
ideal pero el miedo justifica el voto y
es el voto poderoso botero con miedo al
otro candidato tal vez más que una
insatisfacción me parece vamos a estar a
washington sabía me la sabía en el trump
ismo tiene recorrido sin donald trump y
formulando te de otra forma a la
pregunta vamos a asistir en las próximas
semanas de estos juicios de estos
litigios que va a presentar donald trump
a oposiciones dentro del partido
republicano que hasta ahora han estado
detrás de él estos años bueno fíjate
como en las últimas horas algunos
senadores republicanos ya han salido
criticando el discurso de trump respecto
a la legitimidad de las elecciones por
lo tanto empiezan a ver situaciones
donde la gente ve que se puede quedar
sin cargo y se quiere marchar quiere
decir esto que quieren aspirar a la
presidencia no pero quieren resituarse
es muy interesante lo que comentas el
tram mismo porque aquí ya ha habido
gente por ejemplo en centros de estudio
en el bayern de las democracias
emergentes que están comparando a el
tram mismo con el peronismo argentino es
decir una estructura que moviliza masas
que tiene mucha fidelidad y que aunque
pierda no termina de marcharse nunca es
decir que desde ese punto de vista es
interesante y suscribo trump o la idea
de trump y sus políticas está para
quedarse porque la gente vota trump a un
poco a ciegas y cuando digo eso me
quiero decir que no es tanto votar al
personaje que conocen por televisión
como votar una idea que sobre la mesa
está exponiendo cómo es y estamos hartos
de determinada élite que no nos permite
tener la vida que teníamos 75 años
pero esa vida ya pasó pero hay mucha
gente aquí que se resiste a superar la
que creáis en este tramo mismo sin
trampa en esa idea david
sí sí puedo añadir
sólo una cosa que dice que camps ya
prepaga a la compañía de 2024 para
vuelve a entonces no hay mucho caminado
con camps y tampoco el campismo o sea
que no va a ser tan fácil librarse de
tram va a ser muy interesante en este
punto escucharla la mirada del
historiador del señor james cohen como
historiador y como profundo conocedor de
la realidad de eeuu creo que es
conveniente también que miremos al
pasado del país para entender la
actualidad una fractura así de estas
dimensiones tiene precedentes en
momentos de la historia de eeuu a veces
uno tiene la impresión de estar en otro
siglo porque estamos viendo cosas que
vivimos en otras circunstancias en otros
contextos hace un siglo y medio por
ejemplo cuando se acabó la esclavitud en
el sur de eeuu a partir del año 1865 se
puso en marcha un proceso que se llamaba
la deconstrucción del sur
esclavo es ex esclavos y se convertían
en ciudadanos y tenían aunque tenía muy
poco en términos materiales y eran muy
pobres que tenían el derecho de votar de
estar representados en el congreso y de
tener una serie de derechos democráticos
que antes no tenían y este este régimen
de reconstrucción duró al máximo 10 años
en varios casos en varias regiones del
sur - y luego se acabó la construcción y
voy a poder blanco y se excluyeron otra
vez los negros de la ciudadanía tu
tronco al menos tuvimos la impresión de
estar en un momento de regreso hacia
otras épocas de exclusión pero en cada
contexto histórico es nuevo también hay
que tomar en cuenta todo lo que está
pasando en este razonamiento sobre el
pasado es importante pero no debe de ser
demasiado mecánico
les quiero preguntar sobre el voto
latino y también sobre las repercusiones
de todo esto en américa latina david las
repercusiones de trump en américa latina
porque creo que por ejemplo bolsonaro ya
ha hablado no como puede influenciar a
una realidad en la que vive tram con
otras en el continente americano en
latinoamérica a la mirada está puesta
sobre lo que está pasando eeuu que en
los cuatro últimos años tram fue una
inspiración con muchos políticos en
latinoamérica y bueno al más más
evidente es en el caso de bolsonaro que
que no solamente reivindica una
ideología similar a lo de tram pero en
su manera de hacer política se inspira
mucho de y ahora con los hijos de
revolucionario tienen unos vínculos
que se han construyendo vínculos con el
equipo político
que maneja la política de trump y
y para bolsonaro ya está pensando en su
reelección y si llega si se tramita
reelegido rabat y yo creo que va a ser
mucho más fácil para él el otro tema es
la amazonia sí sí baiden está electa do
brasil va a sentir una presión
internacional sobre el tema de las
quemas en la amazonia en caso que donde
está dirigido mucho menos repercusiones
de la elección de uno u otro vamos a
hablar del voto latino en los minutos
que nos quedan claro nos dicen que el
voto latino cada vez es más decisivo
pero cuesta entender la tendencia del
voto latino porque parece por ejemplo en
arizona y en florida ha pesado muchísimo
el voto latino mucho peso pero los
latinos se han decantado de formas
distintas en florida hacia el lado
republicano y en arizona hacia el lado
demócrata román pienso que no hay voto
latino hay de tendencia en el voto
latino por ejemplo en florida hay muchos
cubanos y muchos venezolanos entonces
podemos decir que casi la política
exterior de trump hacia venezuela hacia
cuba era para ganar este voto y parece
que ha funcionado porque ha ganado en
florida en arizona
hay que ver el país de origen es decías
que los migrantes que viene de media
censal de méxico son un poco más
demócratas pero también hay otras
tendencias porque se dice que la primera
generación vota la vota demócrata pero
la segunda y la tercera se vuelven más
conservador y más republicanos porque se
consideran como americanos entonces
ellos también tienen miedo de lo nuevo
de los galgos y también hay el tema de
la religión el catolicismo que lo hacen
vota a republicano a veces entonces hay
unas tendencias pero no voto latino
unificado sabe ávila washington dice en
algunos analistas que el partido
republicano podría reconstruirse basando
precisamente su objetivo en conquistar
el voto latino definitivamente no sé si
hay parámetros de los que hoy se esté
hablando de cómo han votado los latinos
en estas elecciones
bueno hay algunos algunos que estáis
comentando sobre la mesa porque
realmente él es cierto que el partido
republicano ha sido hábil en explotar la
situación en los países de origen
especialmente cuba y venezuela y
colombia para dirigirse a la población
de estos países especialmente en florida
e incidir en el voto es cierto que las
estrategias de los partidos aquí van
encaminadas a encontrar este tipo de
votante y atraerlo pero de todos modos
no nos equivoquemos hay una gran
cantidad de latinos especialmente en la
florida que han votado con sólo dos
ideas en la cabeza la cartera es decir
dónde puedo encontrar un trabajo que no
requiera una carrera universitaria y la
religión y dentro de la religión a un
subcontinente si me permite es que es
todo el tema del aborto y desde el punto
de vista
la claridad claridad de trump contra
determinadas situaciones en el campo de
la religión y el aborto pues le han
atraído muchísimos votos del campo
hispano muchísimas gracias sábila desde
washington historiador james cohn y
también mis compañeros de ha vivido
comer sano y goma o web ha sido un
placer analizar eeuu con ustedes
seguramente me temo que vamos a seguir
haciéndolo muchísimas gracias a ustedes
hasta la próxima semana en primera plana